if you're feeling pretty secure and how
much you love insecure here are five
other titles totally worth checking out
on this week's binge guide
the hit hbo show that was created by and
stars issa ray just wrapped up their
fourth straight fresh
season and that finale was crazy am i
right so if you guys are
all done watching insecuring you've
already checked out the new one-off
podcast looking for latoya and you're
looking for more shows to watch
you're in luck because we have a list of
shows for you guys that include some
other living singles
dope queens and so much more starting
with our certified fresh pick high
fidelity
this adaptation of nick hornby's novel
and a fresh take on the 2000 film of the
same name stars zoe kravitz as a record
store owner revisiting past
relationships through music and pop
culture
it's a lot like insecure in the sense
that high fidelity looks at the
complexities
and awkwardness of relationships and
more importantly breakups
and what critics say is a show that is
as witty as it is emotionally charged
binging season 1 will take you about
five hours but all the different top
five lists you create
will be endless next on our list is this
week's brand new pick
i may destroy you the certified fresh
first season is currently underway on
hbo and addresses the question of sexual
consent and how we make the distinction
between liberation
and exploitation in the current
landscape of dating and relationships
creator and star michaela cole whose
netflix series chewing gum
is also worth checking out carries the
show that critics say is at once brave
and delicate as it untangles the trauma
of sexual assault with dark humor and
moments of deep discomfort
the first season will wrap later this
summer with 12 installments but at just
30 minutes per episode it'll be a quick
binge and hopefully inspire
plenty of conversation about very
sensitive yet very important subject
matter
and our audience pick this week is going
to owns queen sugar
with an average audience score of 91
percent this show was created by ava
duvernay
and oprah winfrey and is based on the
novel of the same name
it follows the lives and drama of three
estranged siblings who moved to
louisiana to claim their inheritance
in 800-acre sugarcane farm with three
fresh seasons under its belt critics say
queen sugar rises above melodrama and is
an alluring
unhurried and powerful portrait of a
fractious black american family
it'll take you close to 56 hours to
binge the first four seasons but if ava
and oprah are behind it
you know it'll be worth it next up is
our throwback pick
living single this sitcom that was an
inspiration for the hit show friends
aired on fox from 1993 to 1998 and
followed the lives and loves of
roommates living in a brooklyn
brownstone
featuring stars like queen latifah kim
fields erika alexander
and kim coles one critic said the best
aspects of the show are the chemistry of
the core cast the warm apartment setting
and the fun often physical humor
this one has a bench time of 59 hours
and will make you yearn for the simpler
time of 90 sitcoms
and finally for our editors pick this
week we're going with two dope queens
this podcast come to life is taped
before a live studio audience and
features jessica williams and phoebe
robinson
dishing on various topics like race sex
hair and living in new york while
showcasing some of the ladies favorite
stand-up comedians and
other stars and while guests have
included names like lupita nyong'o
lizzo and keegan michael key critics
love the chemistry between phoebe and
jessica
saying this show dispels any doubts
about giving a podcast a prime time slot
with just four episodes per season you
can binge two dope queens in just under
four dope hours so what are you waiting
for do it all right friends hopefully
this will help you through your next few
binge sessions be sure to let us know
what you are currently streaming in the
comments section and if you don't want
to miss out on
any more recommendations based around
the shows and movies that you love
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell because we got your
back
right here on the rotten tomatoes binge
guide thank you for watching and we hope
to see your face in the next video
bye
[Music]
you